that's breaking news the uk's office for
national statistics
says an estimated 1 in 65 people in
england
had covert 19 in the last week sky
science correspondent thomas moore has
been looking at the numbers uh thomas
uh tell us more
yes so 951 700 people across the uk are
estimated to have had covered in the
week to the 25th
of july that's a rise of almost 14 and a
half percent
from the previous week and this is
covers at a period when
the daily dashboard numbers had declined
by a
third and scientists had been scratching
their heads over
what was going on why there had been
this abrupt apparent
rupt abrupt turnaround uh in the the
cases being reported through the
government dashboard
uh and this shows that in fact uh it
wasn't a real decrease that
uh numbers are still rising that part of
the third wave now seems to be
going below the radar that the official
stats are not capturing the full picture
of what's going on
why might that be the case well it could
be that secondary school aged children
are no longer having to do twice weekly
lateral flow tests
these statistics from the ons show that
in fact
three percent of that age group
are likely to be infected with the virus
they're not potentially showing up in
the deadly stats because they're
less likely to have symptoms they may be
asymptomatic
and they might not be coming forward for
testing that matters because they can
still pass on the virus of course
and we might get this surge later if
this will be a worry to the nhs
perhaps they've been looking at the
daily government stats thinking
perhaps the pressure is off from the ons
statistics
it does look like we can expect a
further increase in hospital admissions
even though an increasing proportion of
the population is being double jabbed
it's complicated thomas but you've
explained it very clearly thanks very
much